talk about before we get into uh the the
sort of uh
the meat of the covid situation at the
moment can we just have a quick word
about the situation
in southampton i mean what what is your
understanding
as to what's gone on well i've spoken
to the defense secretary the home
secretary
and of course this is a live police
investigation so there's a limit to what
i can say
but i can confirm that the that the crew
are safe and that the operation to
secure the vessel has
uh concluded successfully and really i'd
like to pay tribute to the
police and the armed forces who did such
an exemplary job
as you say this is what they train for
and this is what they're there for to
protect our
country and they did that to
to such a high standard that we come to
expect
can we turn our attention then to free
school meals
has the government i mean is there an
acknowledgement that you've
totally misjudged the mood of the nation
when it comes to this issue
well what i'd say is that we've put in
a huge amount of extra investment to
support people during this coronavirus
pandemic and we put in
an extra 20 pounds a week into universal
credit
and we've uh also put money directly
into
supporting people in these circumstances
i think what i'd say is that
i i i agree very strongly with
the purpose of the campaign run by
marcus rashford i think we're all
inspired by the way that he's led that
campaign
and the purpose is that no child should
go hungry and that's right the question
is how we then fulfill that
and so i think that there is a you know
there's a there's a need during this
pandemic and
at all times for the country to come
together
and to support people and that's that's
what we're doing putting that investment
in
yeah but over the weekend as you'll be
you should be very well aware we've seen
businesses
charities councils including
conservative
run councils all stepping up to the
plate and saying they're going to
provide these free meals
despite of the official government
position
that goes to show doesn't it that
actually more direct action is needed
i think that it's absolutely wonderful
the companies that have come forward
and uh are are playing their part
and supporting people in these very
difficult times
i also think that you know it's
brilliant that the councils are coming
forward
having been funded by central government
63 million pounds has gone to councils
so that they can do exactly what you say
so that they
can support people and make sure that
everybody and every
child gets the support that they need
and you know in my own local council i
looked up the figures it
that they were granted a three-quarters
of a million pounds
by the uh government in order to
support children in
who who are in need extra money that's
gone in
and now councils across the country as
you say along with businesses and
lots and lots of individuals are coming
forward with this sort of support
and the support from the councils of
course i welcome it because that is the
council's delivering
with the funding that has been provided
by central government
and i i saw yesterday that marcus
rashford called for
people to work together and for
collaboration on this
and i strongly agree with that it's
about making sure that we give
everybody the best possible
start in life in what a very difficult
circumstances well in terms of coming
together then shouldn't
the prime minister meet marcus rashford
and and
and get a you know a proper first-hand
chat with him about what it is like to
be a child in poverty
well i know that they've been
communicating and in fact i'm
here and going to be talking about
a different food issue which is hospital
food the need to improve
hospital food working with crew leaf and
the prime minister
on that so yes of course we we work on
a huge array of issues which are about
you know improving people's lives
improving hospital food is
one of them very very important subject
and uh
we i'm confident that we can make sure
hospital food
contributes to your recovery and then
also
you know on on making sure that all
children get
get good food in this country we we can
deliver that we should be able to
deliver that and we must deliver it
hence the money that the government's
put in working with councils
working with the businesses who've
stepped up so
i i think this needs to be a big team
effort everybody coming together
across party lines to make sure that
that
children get the support that they need
but within all of that there is still
the problem that people
you know it sounds great in a way when
you say well we're providing the money
we're just providing it in a different
way
the children's commissioner and
longfield told sky news yesterday
she's horrified by the debate the royal
college of pediatrics
and child health are very unhappy about
it obviously the welsh
and scottish governments the northern
ireland executive are all stepping in in
a way that the westminster government
isn't isn't it time that
whatever you've put forward in terms of
finances in other ways
you just need to react to what the
people in this country seem to want
well look i i also want no child to go
hungry of course
and the putting in money to deliver that
through councils who often know
better you know are close to their local
community
and can therefore make the decisions uh
to
to make sure that the people who really
need it get the support
i think that's the way to do this and we
have put in that forgive me
forgive me for interrupting but if
that's the case then why didn't you do
that during the
the summer i mean obviously during the
summer you relented you
decided to put on free school meals if
it applied then why does it not apply
now moving forward into next year
well of course the situation was was
different in the
in the summer and in the spring and that
was because schools were out
for months and months and you know
people were
often being educated at home and there
was uh there were you know because of
the pandemic
from september school's been back the
vast
vast majority of children are back in
school of course occasionally
they have to isolate but the vast
majority are back in school
and so i think you know obviously when
they're in school then they then
children get free school meals if they
are
if they need them and we can we can go
to
the system that i think will deliver
best which is making sure that the
councils can support children
with the money provided by central
government uh working together
to try to to try to ensure that
everybody gets the support they need
you know it's a question of how we
deliver on
that and i think with the 63 million
pounds that's been
put in that's gone to each local council
that is a good way to deliver on this
this noble ambition
the labour party wants to bring this
back before the commons
for a second vote if that happens
will you vote against this again
um i i'll vote to support delivering
the uh the for the needs of children
uh in the best way that we think is the
most effective
and that's why i supported the obviously
the government motion last week
and yeah we can have we can have votes
on it i think the debate
is uh you know it's perfectly reasonable
to have the debate about
how we do this um what nobody should be
under any question about is whether we
want to
support all children to get a good
food and a good meal at all times and of
course we do
in the same way that i as health
secretary want to make sure that
everybody in hospital gets good food
and that all patients can have food that
helps contribute to their
recovery you know that's what i came on
to talk about uh
today but i'm quite happy to answer the
the questions about the
free school meals issue because i think
it's
i think it's important that that um
to get the explanation across that we
are putting this money in
it's a question of how it's best
delivered and i think that councils have
got a really important role in that
and can we talk about test and trace
because it was reported over the weekend
that
um that you're considering uh people who
are contacted via test and trace saying
they've been in contact with someone who
has
tested positive that their isolation
time will be reduced from 14 days
to seven because you you are struggling
with compliance
and is that led in any way by the
science
well this is entirely led by the by the
clinical science
um this question uh it's it's always
under review
you might remember that a couple of
months ago we increased the amount of
time that people who
have a positive test have to isolate
from seven days
to ten days that's a clinical decision
in fact i was in contact with my french
opposite number over the weekend because
there they have reduced the amount of
time people have to isolate based on
their clinical advice so it isn't about
the
compliance issue it's about the overall
clinical judgment
of what time is uh required for
isolation
obviously i'd rather have isolation as
short as is
reasonably possible because of the
impact it has on people's lives
but it must be safe and that as
precisely as you say it's a clinical
judgment and so we'll be listening
very strongly to what the clinicians say
and be guided by the science as we have
been in all decisions in this
in this pandemic i mean in terms of
keeping a handle on this pandemic which
clearly is is not working very well at
the moment test and trace is not working
properly sixty percent of
of the people who tested positive being
successfully contacted and told to
quarantine on test and trace
last week that's the lowest figures ever
we're told it has to be 80
for it to be effective what is going
wrong with test and trace
why is it not delivering and is it time
to get new leadership in there
well no just to on a point of detail in
your question
um that the way you said it is wrong 80
percent of people who test positive we
managed to
get in contact with this test and trace
system is incredibly important
and if you think about it we've built
one of the biggest organizations in the
country
in a few short months and that has been
a a huge challenge and i pay tribute to
everybody
from from dido harding and throughout
the leadership team and everybody
involved on the ground and delivering
that service and what it delivers is now
over a third of a million tests a day
there were 340 000
uh yesterday a capacity
on track to get to half a million by the
end of the year
and now over a million people have been
asked to isolate by nhs test and trace
and that's important because that's over
a million people who could have
inadvertently passed on the virus who
instead were
asked to isolate now that is an
extraordinary scale of operation and
it's been built in a record amount of
time and it's
been a absolutely huge challenge and it
continues to grow
what we need also to do is get the get
the
the growth in cases under control the
increase in cases
has slowed but it's still going up and
so we need to keep
following the rules all of us all of us
have got a role to play
and we've got to keep under review what
the rules are in each individual area to
try to make sure that we bring that
curve
and get it going down rather than going
up as it is at the moment
so just a final thought then because
this is continuing to go up whose fault
is that
is it is it down to the way the
messaging is it are we having a lack of
clear messaging is it a
confusion over the tier system is it
just that people aren't doing what
they're meant to do
do well i think if you look right across
europe
we're seeing a rise in the number of
cases
uh in uh in spain overnight they've
brought in a
a curfew and they have moved to the
the sort of tiers system that we
introduced here a couple of weeks ago
in italy uh the number of cases is
rising
uh and and in france and in fact in
germany so
right across europe we're seeing the
second wave the the question is what we
can do to
stop it becoming more hospitalizations
and more deaths which sadly we've also
been seeing
and the answer to that for every single
person watching
is that by following the rules and by
respecting social
distancing hands face space the basics
and then of course in the areas of
higher prevalence following the rules
for that level not meeting people
outside your
your household that is what we can all
best do
to keep this virus under control and to
help this country
come through it it's again it's about
collaboration it's about people working
together
uh putting politics to one side and
doing everything we can
and each of us has a role to play